yeah welcome to this video play
toothpick on toothpick are from the US
and let's for change play the London
system uh-huh quick quick Queen B 6 okay
let's just protect me too dumb okay so
it probably wants to play night Bishop
age 52 g6 yeah not much I can I can do
against that okay is he threatening to
take and play night before maybe not
deform
mmm 195 something like that don't know
takes takes Knight take a can really
take with the knight on d4 look so
really wacky but it seems to seems to be
playable okay whatever let's just get
out of the sea file and continue to
develop when I went for the London I
wasn't really counting on a quick
opening vase to victory anyway I was
just trying to play something else it's
not exactly playing for an edge okay
exchanged on before surprises me a bit
not not a bad move but didn't really
expect that and now Quinn back
mysterious yeah maybe we should be 60
but okay I can even take with the poor
now not that it necessarily leads to
anything okay let's do that at least if
he goes Bishop d6 now I have Bishop b5
check and spawn has some castling rights
check let's let's do that so not the end
of the world but still came
yeah where to go now Bishop d3 is really
a bit of a bit of a little move not a
move that it's very exciting but I don't
know where else to go with the Queen son
that's let's just do that but also
simplifies matters a bit yeah I can I
can take you and take on h7 being just
scream and I'll do that
crave maybe you can play just just King
e7 king is seven rook rook age eight
this kind of idea yep simple but
probably effective okay need to retreat
the Queen
check yeah but i had a queen age three
at the end so I k is it taking here but
what what is happening if I just move
the earth porn come on show me what you
get okay I saw that you can take on a
form we catch two and take on f4 but
thought that I yeah I can just I can
just drawn thought I can return it to
play 93 and now i'm just a piece up for
nothing not even even a check on ya
check on g4 h5 i can just play queen of
three
queena 5sg for black forfeits due to
this connection okay yeah well if you
don't find the resign button sometimes
you find the disconnect button you know
okay well you should have just played I
think just Luke age 8 and this is this
is still something you can try i mean
it's so it's an open line i probably
would have played age three but maybe
this is the better choice attending 95
is probably better this is better I
don't need to play h3 at the moment in
95 will conveniently stop the pressure
against edge to this isn't so dangerous
really because so much as exchange now
yeah he just gave away the h-bomb if he
plays a normal movie i'm probably not
much going on just taking for example or
play age six then ruki eight or
something um yeah not yeah i could have
could have taken earlier even but but
now I really need to and its really app
it's just a pawn basically not no
serious compensation alright thanks for
watching